just uh ti doing that we're live with
the daughters yeah pretty interesting
anyway really okay we are live
officially for episode number one tell
me what episode this is one thirty four
thirty four thirty four episodes with an
eight time emmy award winning chris
hanson legend in the house thank you for
having us yes yes it's good to have you
on i mean if you listen if you google
chris hanson if you go on youtube and
put your name you'll see videos 10 20 30
40 50 million view videos crazy with the
show you you you catch a predator and
yeah you've been doing this tv stuff
since 1981 i want to say 19 40 years
that's that to last that long i was 12
when i started
but
by the way we got a lot of things i want
to go through with you times have
changed and and uh
i watched some of your videos i watched
the older ones i watched some of the
newer ones i watched the
to the the guy with the pizza who
offered so classic
connecticut yeah well imagine this
when we first did the
initial predator investigation which was
18 years ago last month
we merely had decoys in chat rooms on
aol and yahoo that was it
that's all we had today
there's been as you guys know an
explosion in the number of social media
platforms upon which predators can
approach children
there's their dating apps that didn't
exist before they're tick-tock they're
you know interactive games and it's i
have a hard time keeping up we're going
to go out and do a predator
investigation another one this week and
we've been doing them and still 18 years
later these guys show up
and some know who i am
some do not
but it's the same
profile of a guy same same profile of a
guy is it easier to catch them today or
30 years ago 20 years ago
it's a draw for this reason
we had the drop on them
18 years ago because
people didn't know this investigation
was going on the police were doing this
icac was doing this the
internet crimes against children but
guys would walk in thinking okay this is
great you know i've found my target and
today people know i mean guys walk into
these investigations where i'm not
involved that the fbi is doing or you
know some sheriff's department and they
say oh i know i'm getting arrested but
at least chris hansen's not here i'm not
going to be on television on youtube i
got to think the last person you want to
see walk into a room if you're all by
yourself is chris hanson we usually
start pretty much close to nine i think
pat and i were running five ten minutes
late
individually just because we were like i
don't want to be the first person to
walk around first hand
but you get that joke quite often yeah
actually they have a seat right over
there you know it's funny because the
whole have a seat which is the name of
the my youtube channel i have a suit
with chris hanson and we use it for a
lot of other things too but
it
i didn't
mean it to be a catchphrase it was
merely a way of controlling a volatile
situation
yeah i need you to have a seat right
over there i have a seat in fact you
know south park did a parody
and the magic power
to
have a seat right over there and and uh
it was pretty funny
let me ask you so you've been on oprah
you've been on kimmel you've been on
conan you've been on stuart you know uh
john you've been on everything pretty
much that they've had you on have you
noticed uh a
uh uh you know how stories like for
example the other day i'm talking to
someone about a mob movie can they
contact me about potentially do you want
to fund this mob movie and you know we
can go sell this and then i contact a
few people that i know and they said
well the market today doesn't buy mob
movies like they did before sure we're
in the 90s you know the 2000s you had
good fellas you had carlito's way you
had you know scott not scarface carface
is old you had all these movies that
would come out right casino casino and
nowadays the last uh uh
big mob movie that came out was irish
man and netflix didn't they paid 140
something million dollars and it wasn't
like the most profitable opportunity for
them so producers are going away from
these mob movies today that's what i'm
hearing in the market
are you noticing media's level of
interest in the topic of catching
predators the way you're doing it
increase today are they less interested
today and why i think it's increased
because
we're now into the third generation of
people who follow this for a lot of
different reasons you've got younger
people who caught it on youtube you've
got people close to our age watching on
television and a generation older than
that who think oh it's great chris
hanson goes out and catches these creeps
so i think the interest is there because
crime stories crime reporting continues
to be
so
interesting to people
so compelling and what we do
in the predator investigations and the
other ones we do we take people inside
the commission of a felony we take them
to places they wouldn't normally see
they hear things they wouldn't normally
hear so we do all the work
take on the risk so people can
have a view of this world they wouldn't
normally have and it's real this isn't a
made for tv movie this isn't a
scripted series for netflix or discovery
plus or any of the others this is real
life stuff yeah i would assume they
would want who currently
because it was on dateline right it was
on dateline and then we did crimewatch
daily which was a syndicated show i did
for a few years and we had a predator
investigation that i went out and shot
on my own
and that ultimately became part of my
deal with crimewatch daily and now we're
shooting them again
with uh transition films uh and that's
gonna turn into a series for a new
crime streaming network called true blue
that's gonna launch do you think you're
like the og in this meeting like i
watched you
for years and then i would that kind of
stemmed off to cheaters right i'm sure
you're familiar with this show which and
then from there it got really juicy with
like first 48 which they would take the
police officer took 48 hours to find him
and then all the stuff that came out on
netflix making of a murderer
even the the tiger king was sort of in
this elk of
crime mystery drama
and it were you the og in this or did
you get this idea from someone else
initially you know
this goes back a long ways i was in
local news before i went to nbc and when
i was in detroit
as a reporter
i was tagging along with the narcotics
team the no crack task force this was 86
87 when crack had taken over detroit and
i was allowed access
to this
group local pd
dea
other federal agencies and we would go
in on these raids right so it'd be the
shotgun the ram the helicon
my cameraman some other cops than me i
mean we went on these raids we lived
this for years and on one of those raids
targeting a drug gang called the
chambers brothers
the cops found these videos
i mean you know old-fashioned 1980s
vhs
of the gang
capturing their ill-gotten wealth
24-karat gold faucets cars and this one
iconic video of this guy one of the
chambers brothers no shernan money money
money we rich goddammit i'm gonna buy
three cars tomorrow and a jeep and blah
blah blah blah blah
i got those videos
and we did a five-part series called all
in the family
in about
1987.
and i held these tapes for 18 months
because this investigation was ongoing
and we broke this thing and the power of
taking people inside
this drug world
caught on and suddenly i was in detroit
but in the middle of a national story
because
you might as well have had hidden
cameras in there and it struck me right
then
the power
of this kind of journalism this kind of
enterprise reporting where you get
inside the story yeah and i never forgot
that
so we had done a lot of hidden camera
investigations with nbc they gave me a
pretty long leash which i always
appreciated
and when this opportunity came up
to work with perverted justice the
online watchdog group which essentially
would find these guys and post them on
their website i thought if we could
combine this with our ability to wire a
house with hidden cameras and
microphones it could be compelling and
so we did it now i didn't know in the
beginning whether or not i had just
wasted tens of thousands of dollars of
the network's money and no one would
show up or
if it would become what it did
and within
the first 45 minutes of our
investigation in bethpage long island we
had two guys
ready to show up at the same time
and before the end of that two and a
half day investigation we had 17 guys
surface
and i thought oh my god what have we got
here
and i thought we'd do it two or three
times and no one would show up and here
we are 18 years later crazy but
just out of curiosity because
the
you are known as one of the best
investigative journalists that we've had
in america i mean your name is on that
list everywhere you don't win eight
emmys you know by pure luck you know
what actually but more frequently
since i walked in the building
but here's a question for you
i'm so curious if we were in high school
together and we're in 10th grade i'm
actually very curious to know who you
were in high school
you know i was kind of a
quiet kid at first
you know i went to brother ice high
school outside of detroit all boys
catholic school and freshman year was a
little bit of an adjustment i didn't
have a lot of friends there and
sophomore year i came into my own
started playing sports made some good
buddies buddies i have to this very day
and i guess i was you know okay student
ultimately figured it out
had a lot of fun
had some really good friends
and
but
well a bit of a ham maybe
but not a class clown kind of a guy who
you know took part in everything but
didn't wake up till my sophomore year
and all of a sudden
you grow eight inches in in in six
months and you know things change you're
somebody yeah
and i always had a job i always had an
interest in
the media
when i was 15 years old
jimmy hoffa was kidnapped from a
restaurant a mile and a half from my
home and i was fascinated by it
the
cops were there yes yeah
exactly
and uh it was right at maple and
telegraph the restaurant's a different
name now but it's still there and i used
to ride my bike up there
and the local reporters from channel 7
action news were there and the network
guys were in and i just got bit by the
bug
and so when i went away to college
at michigan state university i just on
the first day
you know figured out where the college
radio station was signed up no
experience you know in those days high
schools didn't have radio and tv
you had you know the yearbook
and um started so you know even your
major was in communications like you
knew you were going to go into
telecommunications in those days yeah so
did you when you were a kid did anybody
bully you did you did anybody
push you around or piss you off to
create a
feeling of underdog did that ever happen
to you growing up no i i didn't i had a
wonderful childhood okay you know we we
weren't wealthy but we were on the
periphery of
you know well-to-do people upper class
yeah i've been you know but i hustled i
mean i paid half my tuition at
brotherize high school i worked in the
back of mr pastries bakery i hauled
drywall to pay for college and you don't
know what hard work is until you haul
drywall
i showed up at the first day 17 years
old my drywall hauling partner was lee
arthur ramsey
i jump in the truck i've got the wrong
boots the wrong gloves and there's a
pack of cigarettes on the dashboard of
the truck big truck
and he says uh you want a cigarette he
goes no i don't smoke he was good you're
gonna need all the breath you got
[ __ ] let's go
[Laughter]
who do people say you sound like i mean
you've got a voice for radio but also a
face for tv that's a compliment well
that's very kind who do people say you
sound like you have a very distinct
voice
you know it it is distinct
and the funny thing is that
i had news directors and consultants try
to change it over the years and make it
more
fm or more
broadcast friendly and it it has always
stuck out a little bit i don't know
whether it's a midwest
i hear some midwives nasal into it or or
whatever and you know people have worked
with me on it over the years and it was
what was interesting is when i went to
nbc
we had another show called now that was
anchored by tom brokaw katie couric
and i came from local news
and it's different
you know what you rattle off in two
minutes
at the top of the six is different than
the 15-minute piece you're going to do
for now and literally had
you know executives there
paul greenberg and beth o'connell and
other people sit with me in the booth
and say okay you got to tell a story now
you have to
you know you have to do this differently
and those are the people who helped me
be a
a way better storyteller because you can
wash out there's there's a hazing year
when you started the network and some
people don't make it and without these
people you know i wouldn't have made it
who do you say sounds like i'm actually
curious to know who you said because i
wrote a name down i there's a name i
used to listen to back in the day but
you're it's a more masculine i think
version of casey kasem
that's interesting yeah oh yeah yeah i
have who's it you know
the king of
you know exactly he's got a little bit
of paper i don't know you got my guy all
right i asked the question i asked the
question for one reason the reason why i
asked the questions because
uh you know a couple guys are right now
comment pixma 3mp just said he's james
o'keefe's grandfather
meaning
that no no no what i'm trying not not by
looks by purely of what he does catching
the bad guys getting in your face that
is not an easy job that's not something
that respect mr hanson though let's not
call him a grandfather
i'm old enough to be one point the point
the point i'm trying to make to you is
the fact that to do what you do
because even in the moment when you come
out
you're calm
you know it's not like so so
i go back to like my my belief system
for capitalism
people always cares you know where the
hell does that come from like what do
you out of your mind like
why would you be such a proponent of
capitalism because i grew up communist
and i grew up in a family so if you go
back down to my lineage and you find out
what prompted this level of belief
system to see that i don't like
the concept of manipulation and pinning
people against each other where the guys
that are creating the jobs that are bad
guys all the time i'm sorry i have a
hard time with that i've got a very hard
time with them so that stayed sure since
as a kid so there's nothing for you that
happened where you're like i'm gonna
catch the bad guy very little bullying
no victimization nothing like that but
i always always always
felt a need to stick up for those who
were being picked upon
i always felt very fortunate fighting
for the little guy i always felt very
fortunate to be in this body and again
to not
you know
be wealthy or anything but to to as a
kid but but to be comfortable yeah i
never worried about anything i mean i
worked and i did my part and i you know
those are great experiences for me
to understand hard work to be
in a different group of people to
understand what it was like to come from
the south and work your way up and be in
detroit and make it and make a decent
wage
uh and to hear stories of how that
happened
in a truly urban life
you know we used to listen to different
radio stations that i would hear when i
was in high school working in the
summers hauling drywall it made me a
good reporter it made me
it gave me the ability to go into the
inner city
and be able to connect with people and
have an immediate level of trust where
they would talk to me people who i
didn't know it's not an easy task it's
not an easy task but it's it's a
combination i think
of a genuine sense of curiosity
september 13th september 13th yeah why
are you so curious pat because pat
you've asked that question quite
candidly to a lot of people yeah
but it's a good question for chris
hanson you're like no i really am
genuinely curious about this one no no
okay so let's just say nbc calls you
today saying you're the next guy to go
do the show catching a predator you want
to do that job
no i'm being honest with you i'm being
honest i don't know if i want that life
do you understand what i'm saying to you
there's how many people watching to say
oh you know what sign me up yeah i mean
hanson's here cancel the party no it's
not even that it's the job is
uh
it gets eyeballs but do you really want
to have the to do that job there's got
to be a certain level of true belief to
say i'm i want to go do this because i
want to correct an injustice that's why
we said that about james o'keefe it's
like do you want that life what he's
doing he's very noble yeah and
hard-hitting and investigative
you think he's got an easy life you
think he goes to sleep uh
you know gets his eight hours of sleep
every night okay you know james will
keep project veritas yeah so that's
that's not an easy life no it's not
that's why i'm asking a question to see
what was the wiring who was the
individual you know that's the part that
makes the story interesting folks here's
what i want to talk to today uh with
chris chris
there's a few things that's on my mind
so one
i'm a parent i got four kids i'm
concerned okay my kids are ten eight
five and eight months okay and i watched
i watched a movie called disconnect i
don't know if you've seen it or not if
you haven't seen it i'll tell you the
premise of the story and if the audience
hasn't seen it it's mind boggling i
think every parent needs to watch this
movie it doesn't have the highest scores
it's not like a
movie that won awards but if you're a
parent do yourself a favor put this on
the list go watch it this weekend and if
your kids are old enough i'm gonna watch
this thing with my kids in about a
couple years i'm gonna watch this with
my kids i'm preparing them for them to
watch as kids i want to talk about uh
kanye and t.i a part of t.i is the fact
that how protective he is with his
daughter every year the fear of a father
to go check to see if she's a virgin or
not i don't know if you're worried this
story no i've read about it yeah so we
can talk about that and kanye and pete
davidson right now with kim going back
and forth what is the effect of that on
the kids because is there anything that
they're doing that's hurting the kids
and they're not realizing it how
public they've made it and the you know
tinder
bumble some of these dating sites today
the other day adam's uh
uh famous for swiping right he doesn't
need to but he's famous for swiping
right this weekend this was leo's
birthday right happy 40th birthday to
leo okay we go to bodega and i'm like
thinking we're going to la solas we end
up going to miami hour drive and i go in
there there's 20 girls around adam i
mean it's like girls are just enamored
with this guy they're handsome he's a
handsome fellow thanks guys yeah
compliments will get you everywhere but
here's what happened to him last week
tinder which he called me at two o'clock
in the morning shivering he was nervous
tinder apparently he swiped right with
somebody where they sent you a message
and they said what to you
well it was on hinge but
and uh you're serious unhinged yeah oh i
keep thinking
yeah they they gave me a warning saying
someone you've connected to we've
identified as being a fraudulent
individual
you know disclaimer alert dot dot dot be
careful with and it actually intrigued
me more i was like well hold on let me
let me find out more about this yeah
but uh she'll be canceled so they
canceled her here's the story like this
is a story from uh
uh uh uh tips for online dating how to
keep yourself safe in 2022 we'll start
there and we'll see
uh where we go from there tips for
online dating how to keep yourself safe
in 2022 wedding stats and netflix junkie
number one get contact details
collect some basic information about
them even if it's just an email address
phone number you need more than two
their photo and username to go on the
site where you met number two follow
their online footprint
comb social and google it's not too late
to bail if you
uh unearth concerning the information
three video chat your date before
meeting them pretty interesting four
know the most common red flags are they
ranting against blm or another movement
as you've met are they judgmental of
someone of a group of individuals you
learn a lot about them five
delete them when in doubt six drive
yourself or take public transportation
seven
let someone know where you are uh as
you're going on the date whatever it is
you're doing don't go without people
know where you are so
people nowadays are dating in a
different way it's no longer hey meet
mary i met mary and it's how people meet
it's today
i know people
who have met on
match.com who are in long-term
relationships and married it's kind of
successful successfully wonderful human
beings
and
you know i
was never in the mix to do that
but that's how people meet today
and there's nothing wrong with it but
you have to remember
my overarching rule which is if you
don't know somebody in real life you
don't know them right so just because
somebody says they're a wealthy
physician and they drive this car and
they live there that doesn't mean
anything online
and those
guidelines those suggestions are very
good ones for safety
because
it is a
tremendous opportunity for scam artists
you know we've seen the tinder swindler
on
netflix i'm working on right now one
right now where
40 women
were courted by one fellow
they're all in their 20s
and
each one of them was physically
or sexually assaulted by this guy
and then harassed
they all got together online started
telling their stories to each other
put together a case interesting handed
it to me
essentially with a bow on it for a story
that we are now shooting
and this guy was operating on facebook
he was operating on other social media
platforms but he was able to
gain the confidence of these women
the money that he took from them was not
as big as the tinder schwindler
but the the sexual violence
the physical violence the abuse and
harassment
is far worse i think
so does he know you're you're up to what
you're up to or not
we're interviewing victims right now
really starting next week so how did
these so how did these folks reached out
to me on social media i know but how did
the 40 find each other well
somebody posted
beware of this guy
he's a bad guy this is what he did to me
and somebody saw that and said oh me too
and then suddenly there are
38 40 women
with the same story
now before we move on the tinder
swindler i mean this is taking over
netflix people are talking about this
left and right great story what are your
thoughts on that story well i think you
know this guy has gotten away with a lot
of bad stuff
right he is a great con man and i think
it was brave for these women to come
forward because it's hard to do that
it's hard to realize you've been scammed
but this guy was very good i mean he had
the whole back story he had you know do
you want to get on my private plane and
fly to albania with me i mean you could
see how
an intelligent successful woman
might buy into that
you know everybody's got a every date
starts with the first date right
everybody's got a little bit of puffery
in them right
but
not to this level right you know i think
this rock once said uh
on your first date you don't show up
yourself you send your representative
right
so but he got caught this guy the tender
swindler right but what's amazing to me
is
how few criminal charges he's faced now
again i get he's overseas and now
there's some civil action that's been
taken by the family he claimed to be
right of family yeah the the
jewel people
and uh and i guess he did 15 months or
something like that on a related charge
but it's hard to prosecute these people
i mean we we once did a series
on online scammers you know to catch a
con man and some of this stuff was
nigerian based
and the network gave me
a year and a half
and access to three or four different
producers who would rotate in and out
and it took that long to smoke these
guys out of nigeria because they
typically work
or in west african cafes and they don't
come out they try to get you to send the
money
and finally
after more than a year with
uh aliases and names like you know jimmy
de money and rich greenback and you know
kind of a tongue-in-cheek thing we got
these guys to meet us
in london where we set up a a pub with
hidden cameras and they would come and
they ran their scam and we caught them
and it was it was hard work but
you can't do that story
in a week you can't do that story every
year it was it was such a big deal
because we pulled it off but it was a
herculean task to do it and that's why
these guys get away with it it's so
ubiquitous right just the internet in
general how are you gonna the guy you're
talking about with the 40 you know the
40 uh
women that came to you right the victims
i came up to you what's your approach
going to be with him
well
we're going to have to be a little bit
flexible but i think ultimately
you try to set up a sting
so maybe
the next victim who we can put in place
to make her seem like
she's a good mark
set up a date
sent him to the travel expenses he shows
up i'm there she's not
confront confrontation are you worried
you're letting the cat out the bag or
well i think it's vague enough
in terms of there's so many of these
guys out there this right now
he's chris is coming for you buddy yeah
i've been muttering one person in the
world you chris hansen oh my god that's
classic i think there's so many of these
guys out there that i i
comfortable talking about aside from
dating i mean how many freaking bitcoin
scammers fake valuetainment accounts
fake sauce talks money fake dvd
non-verified accounts i mean pat
you you've told this
but there were fake chris hanson's
courting
young women to work in in uh
investigations into predators
they were out on social media
so what's the general rule these days
because i mean you've dealt with this i
assume non-stop we have fake
valuetainment accounts you know
messaging people
is there like a go tool like pat read
off these six seven
you know tips
but is there sort of a you know like the
uh the rules for radicals or
online
and they're committing harassment or
violating terms of service for twitter
or
uh instagram
you need to file the report in
in numerous cases where
people have targeted me for harassment
or whatever
you can get that account taken down
but it's it's painstakingly difficult
and to keep track of it all it's just
give you a migrant you know because
there's so many people out there trying
to do it so
you protect yourself as best you can
there's some security people i'm sure
you've got people monitoring
accounts to see what pops up and i've
got people who monitor mine thankfully
because like you can't do it by yourself
yet you don't want somebody out there
saying you're doing something that's
untrue or creating a
misinformation campaign because people
do it every day it's not that hard to do
i mean people pop up i report accounts
all the time
that are
have my picture in my name instagram
does not do a good job of deleting
terrible by the way they're they're
i don't i don't know if it's intentional
i don't think it's i don't know if it's
volume but they can probably do a better
job because would you say the number one
app that they're targeting would be
facebook or is it more instagram and
tick tock due to the age being younger i
think that to me in my experience
instagram has been very responsive when
i've had an issue and i've had far fewer
issues on instagram that i have on on
twitter
twitter to me at least seems to be where
there are more trolls
more people getting away with stuff
harder to report and if you were to look
at what people say about chris hanson on
instagram
he's the goat he's this he's that all
you know 99 positive on twitter
oh he did this he's murdered did you you
know it's just hold on chris are you
saying that there's trolls on twitter
is that what you're saying no shocking
breakthrough toughest people in the
world the keyboard let me target let me
target to one specific topic we'll come
back to this dating stuff i want to i
want to target one specific topic so
i watch this movie disconnect if you can
pull it up let's just start with this so
disconnect there's a story
uh with the actor what's his name jason
bateman okay so he's a great actor
phenomenal job but this story is a story
of a father
uh uh who is working doing what he's
doing his son
in a class look at box office look at
box office 1.5 think about it and i'm
telling you every parent must watch this
movie right so you know this father's
got this kid he's got a daughter and a
son the son falls in love with a kid in
school girl in school
and he tells another guy he finds out
but the guy tells the bully of the
school the bully of the school creates a
face a fake facebook profile with the
girl that he likes his picture on there
befriends all the people in school
thinking that he is the girl
then she reaches out to him
and meaning he acting as if it's her
reaches out to him
saying hey thank you for your help with
some message like that on facebook so i
didn't even know you paid attention to
me so of course i pay attention to you
and then he starts flirting with him
thinking it's her
um
eventually the bully says i'll show you
mine if you show me yours okay
so
he's like really yes
so the bully sends a picture of some
girls you know naked and it's just the
bottom nothing more right
and the guy's like oh my god says then
he sends his picture but he wants the
the the bully wants him to send a
picture with his face in it so he does
they take that picture the next day the
kid who goes to school everybody's
looking at this kid laughing at him
right he's like why is everybody
laughing and everybody starts showing a
picture listen
you send this message and the bully
outs and you know exposes them right so
this kid is devastated
doesn't know what to do he's 12 years
old doesn't know how to handle this
goes home turns on heavy metal music
they're wondering why he's doing that
he's hanging himself
in his room sister walks and holds him
before he kills himself father comes and
says what the hell is going on he says
finally they find that the situation
that goes to the other dads and then
anyways this story right here it's based
on a true story by the way it's based on
a true and it's happening and there's
multiple there are multiple versions of
this i'll tell you what i've done this
on my youtube channel have a seat with
chris hanson in a case where a young man
same thing happened to him
and the mom went to
and not only was this an embarrassment
at school
it got into
different sites that it was being traded
for child porn
it went on twitter and was being
disseminated on twitter they went to
twitter and said take this down
twitter didn't act pretty well for
months and months and months and months
and it's the subject of a civil lawsuit
claiming that twitter was complicit in
the distribution of child pornography
this is real life stuff this happens you
look at the case down in
in naples
not far from here a girl was a very
popular tic-tocker started during the
pandemic 13 14 15. a guy becomes
obsessed shows up at the door with a
shotgun blows open the door
the father is a retired lieutenant from
jersey city pd fortunately had a pistol
shoots him dead
stand your ground case we didn't find
out until
just a month or so ago that this was all
involved in a twitter type thing and it
turns out the guy who was shot dead the
stalker had been in contact with other
kids at her school to get information
about her see this is stories like this
that i mean it's it's you i mean look
it's all great to be on social media you
know it's a part of the fabric of our
society of our lives and kids should be
able to go out and create accounts and
be able to express themselves it's all
good but it's got to be monitored and
the thing that drives me crazy guys
is you see these parents who are
exploiting their children not in this
case i'm not arguing that in the case of
naples but in other cases and i've done
stories on this where parents are
pimping out their kids in these quote
unquote family
channels
and and youtube sometimes doesn't
crack down on this stuff
so they'll
limit monetization on a on a show that i
do exposing this stuff
but the young girl who's being exploited
that show is fine they monetize the the
heck out of it it's it's insane so what
what do you do your parent you're
listening to this okay we've heard many
different things what are the guidelines
because there's a difference between
being too intrusive it's like dad leave
me alone mom leave me alone you know let
me have my own life versus absolutely
you know you know these guys are out
there
well you have to look
when we talk about the drug problem
there's demand reduction we treat it as
an illness sometimes as opposed to a
crime there's no demand reduction
effectively for predators so your best
defense is education and the discussion
you have with your children at home
there's one discussion when they first
get online and have a phone
there are adults out there who want to
trick you kids don't like to be tricked
and as they get older and as you allow
them access to different areas of the
internet you have to up that
conversation
and be very straight up with them and
say look
you don't want to hear this from me
but
i do this for a living i talk to people
who live in this world and and it's
dangerous if you don't apply these rules
they used to say to us when we were
growing up don't talk to strangers good
advice then good advice today but the
problem is the stranger on wednesday is
so adept at grooming your child right
that he's not a stranger on saturday
and i read these transcripts when i go
back and do the podcast predators i've
caught i go back in the cases that we've
already done and i immersed myself in
the transcripts the confrontation the
interview the stuff that didn't
necessarily make the show at the time
and you see this pattern of grooming and
this normalization of adult sex to
children and this
conversation where they try to relate to
a child at a child's level
and it follows a pattern and it's
effective because it works
it works time and time again so if you
eliminate that
you educate
and you prepare
your child
and you have the conversation you have
the conversation and they have to feel
comfortable coming to you you're not
going to take away the internet of the
community i'm saying look do you have
kids
yeah mine are grown i mean my kids my
two oldest are in the business let's
just say let's just say you're you have
a 10 year old kid today have a comment
role play with us what's the
conversation you have a son or you have
a daughter how do you have the
conversation i'm going to let you
visit youtube okay
but i'm going to put protections on this
and you need to know that there are
people on youtube who are creating
content or making shows
that at first appear to be appropriate
for children
cartoonish
but they're not
they're intended to trick you so i'm
going to watch closely
and monitor the content that you view
the shows you watch on youtube
and if i see anything
we're going to have a conversation
and if anybody ever comes to you
who you don't know in real life and
wants to be your friend you need to tell
me about it i'm not going to punish you
but you need to tell me because why
because there are people out there who
want to hurt kids it's a sad reality of
life
it's it's sad but it's true
there are people that's why we have
police that's why we have the fbi that's
why
god great appearance however you want to
phrase it with your belief system in
your own home
i'm here to protect you i'm not here to
punish you and you need to tell me if
something light happens and if there is
a bad guy out there who tries to do
something with you we'll go after him
together now are you specifically saying
youtube for a reason because i would
feel like snapchat would be probably
i use it just yes snapchat using that as
a tick tock snapchat whatever it is and
the thing that
that you really have to be careful with
when the kids get on and play these
interactive games because somebody
posing as a 13 year old in st louis
could be a 55 year old in his mother's
basement wearing his underwear
surrounded by pizza boxers trying to
trick kids
you create these images in a kid's mind
and they get it right but i'll tell you
this early on in the predator
investigations i had a
a group of maybe a dozen 13 14 year olds
and i said show of hands
how many of you been have been
approached online by an adult and it
made you uncomfortable
99
oh wow
how many of you told your parents
two
so they just don't feel comfortable
telling their parents
pat you
dylan um tico and dylan are 10 and eight
and senna is six
five five and and obviously baby
brooklyn
what does that conversation sound like
for the boys versus for the girls in
your mind because and chris you have
what daughters what do you think i have
uh
uh three boys and a girl three boys and
a girl so pat in your minds is that a
different conversation with the boys
versus girls or have you even are the
kids even old enough to have that
conversation when you should you when
should you start having these
conversations what age yeah i'm watching
i'm reading right now the cain velasquez
case you guys are following you know
what happened there with the came
velasquez case i don't know if you know
what happened there
i heard something happen tyler you know
what you know the story
yeah he he uh
somebody had assaulted what his
four-year-old daughter yeah
tens if not like a hundred times and he
shot at the guy but hit the father if
i'm not mistaken
yeah
so so cain velasquez mm-hmm probably not
a guy's daughter you want to mess with
ufc legend yeah and the guy goes and
kills
the guy
kills
he's going after the guy he's going
after the guy but accidentally anyways
so uh he kills that guy or he kills uh
i don't know mr four miles downwards
superior court of allies it's according
to yes ma'am blasphemes with the united
bill early this month after he was
arrested and charged for allegedly
trying to kill a man amongst other
things who was charged himself for
allegedly molesting velazquez's younger
relative right young relative can you
make that a little bit bigger so i can
have known mr velasquez for 11 for 15
years and during this time an active
athlete and ufc represented our company
with dignity always treat others with
respect
dana's talking about he was a model of
example of how professionals should
carry out carry themselves project on a
positive image ufc white has joined
kamar and other people go a little bit
higher anyways so kane has helped me
more occasions okay people are saying
good things about them here's the point
when it comes down to kids
man it's a very
uh different situation
kids sometimes when they're kids they do
things to each other when they're kids
like i got a call
guys running a real estate office and
their kids both
are at the office
young kids okay under 14 under 12
whatever it was
maybe one of them was even four and five
you know young kids that they had at the
office
and they're in the other room doing an
appointment and they come in the two
kids are fooling around with each other
okay
four or five years old okay
and they're like how do we handle this
is this going to mess with their head or
not and they're calling me this is one
the lengthiest conversation i have with
them because they had no idea how to
handle this situation it's a pretty wild
switch whose fault is it in that
situation right four-year-olds fault is
it a five-year-old's far they're both uh
what do you call it they're both
so
i'm like dude i'm not i'm not call
somebody and process it with them but
you know you can't do anything with the
kid at this point
my daughter being five years old you
know other kids come to our house and
they're playing and they're going away
you're always worried about when they go
in the room by themselves the door's got
to be open
you know who they're playing with and
adults got to be watching even if you
let a younger kid watch how disciplined
is that kid to watch even if they're 13
14 years old i'm still not comfortable
with that i'm not comfortable with a
uh babysitter under the age of 40 to be
honest with you i know this sounds kind
of weird i'm just not i'm not
comfortable with that i'm comfortable
with a babysitter that's a little older
but i've had many weird conversations
with the boys many weird conversations
with the boys but with senna you have to
talk to the girl from an angle of look
you have something that guys want
and unfortunately there's some bad
people out there and you need to know
you got to process it with them like
he's talking about my concern here
is not as much the kids as it is the
parents
i yeah we had dinner with a parent the
other day and i said so how do you bring
it up to oh i'm not going to bring it up
to them it's very awkward like what do
you mean that's very ugly ken is 14
years old i'm not going to bring it up
you got to talk to your kid you don't
think he's already she's already going
through it you don't think she already
knows about sex and other people are
trying to get to you and that happened
at 11 years old with boys
you don't think they're doing it at 14 i
think the challenge in here going back
to chris is
help uh
shape the mindsets of
because i don't think school teachers
are doing it because they're worried if
you do it god forbid you offend somebody
with transgender and all these different
you know sensitivities they have what
should parents be thinking about right
now how should they process this well i
think
you know again it's being proactive
and if you need to read a book if you
need to do research if you need help
if you need a professional there's
nothing wrong with that but you need to
at least start having the conversation
and again create the opening
for a child to come to you
and say
i have a question is this okay
is this appropriate
and that's the best you can do and
create that because you can't rely on
the school yes there are internet safety
classes yes there are wonderful
organizations that go into schools to
try to educate kids but at
its
most organic level
it's what happens in the house
and it's the comfort level that they
feel and again it starts you can make
the rules however you want them
computers only in public spaces you know
i control the access to the internet i
control who you talk to on the phone but
at some point they're going to figure
out a workaround
right they're going to get on yeah the
internet yeah and i've had i've given
speeches where fathers say oh just won't
allow it i'll take it away well they can
go to starbucks
they go to the friend's house the entire
cities are wired so you have to say
look
you're protected here this is your safe
area and you're generally safe
everywhere you go
and the reality is when it comes to
predators the vast majority of kids who
are preyed upon are prey them on
somebody they know
right even though there are
many many scary stranger cases and
i deal with them all the time
so it's really about creating the
comfort level
with the family
to say hey
and if you have a daughter
you can talk to your mom if you're
uncomfortable talking to me
but i'm here for you
and there should be nothing off topic
yeah
yeah uh you know
the whole thing when i'm talking about
babysitter under 40. i'm talking about
like guys men women you know it's a
different story when you were doing an
interview and you said in all these
cases you've had with catching a
predator has ever been a woman and you
said none none right none it's never
been uh it's happened but the the
therapists or the experts in the area
have always said to me that when you see
the female predator scenario you're more
likely to see the teacher student the
female predator does not like the
anonymity where the male predator
sometimes can thrive on it
right right so
but you know it's crazy yesterday i
don't know who we're sitting down with
and we're talking about uh
why is it that teachers in florida is
women that are who said that somebody
john said that john said that yes when
we're doing the pbd podcast
prep he says you know florida it seems
like it's the women teachers who take
advantage of young boys how does that
happen how do you have that camera how
different is a conversation with your
sons well we always have some son
traditionally
you know and you hear the comments all
the time like that be a dream come true
or whatever yeah you know it's a fantasy
country for a young man but it's not and
it's inappropriate
it's not healthy obviously
so
you know look i
you know remember
in public school it didn't happen
brother rice but in public school or in
college you know there were very
attractive
professors tas teachers you know
whatever
and there would be chatter amongst the
fellows about that but the reality is
when it comes to young kids and young
boys it's wrong there's we have ages in
the law for a reason you know and it's
illegal to have for an adult to have sex
with a somebody who's
um
a minor
and they
those laws are in place because it's
hard to process how do you talk to your
son about that what do you tell them
like i was 13 years old i'm in eighth
grade my history teacher's name is miss
angulo
everyone being sir every one of us has a
teacher what was that one movie with
dustin hoffman yeah the great graduate
right you know it's a legendary movie so
boys have these fantasy teachers that
they think about that they help them
grow up what do you tell your son
there's no rush
to fulfill this fantasy it's it's
natural to feel it and again i'm not a
therapist i i just play one on tv with
predators but
from where i sit
and having sons who are 30
28 almost and and the youngest my
stepson is is 20.
um
you know they're out of the woods pretty
much but
when my older ones
were younger you know it's all about
respect it's about you know
don't you don't have to rush into this
right you got your whole life to
experience certain elements
right take your time be a kid
yeah that's easy to say it is easy when
you're 15 16 and your hormones are
raging and there's a hot teacher ready i
get it i get it i don't know about that
i lived it with you know two boys you
know i walked in
one time and my son will kill kill me
for telling the story but
you know
we left the house
came back drove by going out to dinner
and the front door was open
and i go
and i go in and i go down the basement
he's in the hot tub
with a girl
and
you know there are
i don't think they're driving yet and i
hauled them out and i said look
first of all
you can't have a party here without
parents home that's number one number
two you put her in a situation where
she could be embarrassed
because you weren't thinking of her
how this may look or appear
so
but they were both what 16 something
like that 15 15
something like that well at the end of
the day there's nothing wrong with it
nothing wrong with it but i had the
conversation right you gotta
you got to see how this could look and
what if
her dad
strolled by would you be comfortable
with that
yeah and think about conversations are
going to work for 15 year olds maybe i
don't know
i just you know let me ask you something
sometimes you pray for the best you know
and hope everybody figures out but i
think if you preach respect yeah
you're halfway there well here's just
another scenario that is a little of a
gray area
because i remember being a senior in
high school and there was like a
freshman girl that the like you're
talking about the laws i was just about
to yeah so how many 18 year old boys are
hooking up with 15 16 year old girls
depending on you're going to school
together like it's not like it's that
big of a difference i joke around with
the girl i dated when i was 18 she was
50 the girl's 38 now with kids that's
like what are we talking about but i
think that's the time it was oh my god
right but at the
that's why in many states if you're 17
15 it's not illegal if you're 30 and 15
it's illegal as it should be
so you know but it's the it's the it's
the 1815 it's the 1916 that's
that's the it's like what is it we go to
high school together we go to school you
know and that's the weird part i'd even
take it a step further that you're
branded for life like i worked with a
guy who i think he might have been 19
and when she was 15 or 16. and her dad
didn't like him and now he's been
branded as a sexual predator well he
probably had to register right or even
if like you're drunk and taking a leak
outside and get arrested you're labeled
as well that's that's obviously you know
at some point
you know in some areas we lost common
sense in this right if a 17 and a 16
year old are dating
and there's an issue
that 17 year old probably should not
have to be prosecuted or registered as a
sex offender i mean that's just common
sense i mean they're within a year or
two of each other and that's why the
laws have changed
now you know if it's the teacher and the
15 year old student yeah different story
different story but i mean we you know
we sometimes in an effort to have zero
tolerance policies yeah
find injustice
uh i think and i don't pretend to have
all the answers but i have seen what
you've said and no you shouldn't if you
get caught
outside a bar urinating in public you
should not have to register as a sex
offender that's not right by the way
like nick mckinley and i were talking
yesterday okay
and nick mckinley from deliver funds
which human trafficking human
trafficking i don't know familiar with
them
for some folks that are listening
uh he's right now uh raising money i'll
put the link below i i gave myself
yesterday if you find it in your heart
to contribute they're going right now
doing stuff with ukraine and russia i'm
going to find the link and put it below
i asked him a question about what's the
profile
of people who
uh
are child traffickers right what is the
profile what does this person look like
what is the profile for parents to know
what the how do you know who's a pre you
know child predator how do you how do
you you really don't is the answer and
that's the frightening part of it we've
had guys surfacing our investigations
are doctors teachers
members of law enforcement
and yes there are characters who surface
who might as well have the word predator
tattooed across their forehead because
they look rangy they've had
criminal contact with the law before in
this area
but i think and again i'm not a
therapist but in my experience these
guys break down into three different
categories there's the younger offender
right who 19 20 21
who finds a girl who's in her early
teens
says well
i have a hard time talking to girls in
person i'm going to do this online if it
works out great at some point she'll be
old enough and it won't be
illegal
we've got the hardcore heavy hitter on
the other side of the spectrum the guy
who would be the little league coach
you know the bad
boy scout leader the guy hanging out at
the food court at the mall this guy is a
stone cold pedophile predator can't fix
him and then you've got this group in
the middle
you know white-collar guys often who
have real jobs and real members of
society and oftentimes have families
they have a predilection towards wanting
to be with a younger boy or girl
but they wouldn't act upon it without
the internet the addictive nature the
anonymity and the 24 7 access and at
some point they get involved in these
conversations and they cross this line
between fantasy and reality and they end
up knocking on our door we had a guy in
our connecticut investigation
who was a real estate executive who i
had met on the commuter train
between connecticut and new york
and here he is showing up for a 13 year
old boy in our investigation in
fairfield connecticut shocking so you
don't know what secret somebody may hold
you know in your everyday
moving around town in your casual queens
it's a very interesting thing you just
pulled up tyler it says profile of a
predator their aim is to gain your trust
first before your child
think about that statement for a moment
your child is not the initial target you
are why because you are the gateway to
your child and your child's trust if the
adult gains your trust he has become a
trusted adult in your child's eyes and
this means your child will be much less
likely to disclose abuse by that person
thinking that you are will be angry with
them or will not believe that this
trusted adult would do such a thing the
information in this section will be
taken primarily from the book the
socially skilled child molesters
differentiate
how is it that so many child molesters
get off uh get by with uh what they do
for decades without being caught first
of all please be aware that they do very
often get
by with what they do are doing because
getting comments like your children
so
interesting trusting your parent first
well that makes me think of larry nassar
or like a doctor jim this is
horrifying what what he got away with
and and how he got away with it for so
many years it was a doctor at michigan
who molested players
um it is
it is up to
school administrators
to monitor this and in the nasa case at
michigan state there were warnings
and because
people in the athletic department were
more focused on football and basketball
they were not focused on this issue with
the gymnasts but you know these brave
women
came forward
not pleasant
hurtful and told their stories and
that's what it finally took
for him to face justice but all what a
horrible human being
it had been worn oh you could feel it
though in the court oh yeah you could
feel the darkness you could feel the
like
you know just the way he would stand
imagine how the parents feel yeah
uh being sometimes
on the other side of the screen didn't
one of the parents jump out or was that
a different case where
there was an incident yeah well one of
the fathers got upset
can you i don't
there's other high-profile stories like
obviously um what was the joe paterno
jerry sandusky yeah crazy situation
i'm sure you have strong jeffrey epstein
epstein harvey weinstein and then and
even within politics everything that
happened with matt gates
a handful of months ago the guy out of
alabama roy moore yeah anthony weiner i
mean so it it crosses the landscape
you're given this profile but what about
these high-profile people the jeffrey
epstein's of the world well i think
congressman yeah it's it's it's
a powerful
narcissistic
personality disorder
and they think that they can get away
with anything they want because they
have wealth and power and epstein's a
great example that because he was so
well politically connected in florida
and i'll tell you an interesting
backstory
a few years before it all exploded i had
a series of meetings here in florida
with
uh investigators and lawyers who were in
the case
and i actually tried to he had already
done his time down here and was out
and i tried to fashion a way to do a
sting
in new york with him and the levels of
security were such that it was virtually
impossible and at the time
victims were not speaking up about it
so honestly i got busy with other
stories it was the miami herald and
julie k brown who stayed on that story
every day
chipped away at it
convinced the victims to speak out the
survivors
and it's that kind of local reporting
that is so important and without the
miami heralds reporting on this
there may not have been criminal charges
uh and so you know i've got to give
a lot of credit to
her and the miami herald and other
people worked on the story there
uh once they indicted him obviously you
know a lot of people jumped in we're
reporting on it but it speaks to the
importance of you really got to stay on
a story like that because it's it's hard
to get at somebody i mean look at how
long it took for the weinstein story
right he was working with women who
would wear two pairs of pantyhose
because
if he got
aggressive with them they'd have one
extra layer of protection imagine going
into a business meeting being a female
executive and thinking you had to wear
two pairs of pantyhose for your
protection how shocking is that
what do you think's gonna happen
what do you mean two pair of pants there
was a victim who wrote an op-ed piece in
new york times yeah about her experience
with harvey weinstein she was an
executive
and she would wear
dress protectively
to give her extra time to extricate
herself if he became aggressive sexually
with her as he was known to do
extra undergarments extra undergarments
speaking of epstein and that just that i
mean the whole thing is horrible for so
many different reasons but when i read
that
for some reason it was just so shocking
that that that
that anyone would have to think that way
and that a guy like that could maintain
power in any industry for decades for
decades
speaking of epstein uh the you know
obviously i don't know if you have
strong feelings on who killed him or
anything like that but his partner in
crime literally was this uh jillaine
maxwell gallania gallane maxwell
uh
what's
we covered what happened with her and
her sentencing she's been convicted yeah
what are you like she's basically
an accomplice in what's going on there
well i think she was held accountable
which is
good and and proper i think the
interesting thing will now be
if she
you know gives a proffer to federal
investigators to say here's what i can
tell you
if you'll cut my sentence
and she's got a lot of time to think
about that now and she's not the kind of
person who's used to being in federal
prison although she deserves to be there
um federal prosecutors will have to
make a decision
and she'll possibly do usually like in
the mafia if you give up the big boss
but the biz boss is dead big boss is
dead but how many other people were
enabling him how many other people
abused young women
in this syndicate and there are
a lot of powerful wealthy men allegedly
who were in this circle did they
actually act did they do something i
don't know didn't you go
into in deep like into didn't you go to
the island didn't you go see his palm
beach place you were investigating a
part of that weren't you a part of it i
didn't really go to the island okay i
mean he went to peter nygard's place
yeah peter nygard we were intimately
involved in that investigation so peter
nygard is the fashion mogul
made genes for any number of private
label
operations and for dillard's i mean big
big business
and he was based in canada but also in
new york and he had a big compound in
the bahamas at nygart very weird looking
thing go to his uh it's like jurassic
park jurassic park just google peter
nygard uh
bahamas compound yeah go to that click
on images you're not going to believe
this guy's place
holy [ __ ]
yeah that doesn't even do it justice
like there's pyramids in there there is
structures in there it looks just like
jurassic park yeah i mean look at that
and what was going on here it's like a
playground for kids what was he doing
yeah so he was it turns out
that
nygard has a history of
sexual abuse and predatory behavior
going back some 50 years involving
thousands of victims
not just models who wanted to work for
him
yeah he prides himself into looking like
a lion he's got he's a 78 year old guy
79 now and he's got this long hair and
he used to have these pamper parties and
he'd invite these women there
but he would
also sexually assault
young women
in the bahamas who would be lured to his
compound they would be drugged
violently sexually assaulted and many of
them were never taken seriously
we got involved in this
uh
a couple years ago and did a documentary
that's now on discovery plus called
unseemly the peter nygard investigation
and the reason this came to light was
his compound was next to
a billionaire
uh hedge fund
investor lewis bacon in the bahamas they
got into a beef over
property lines and environmental issues
and in the course of that legal battle
bacon's people and i'm sure you know who
he is
found all this information out gave it
to investigators
and
i knew some of these investigators and
we got involved in it the new york times
got involved in it the cbc up in canada
got involved in it and we
put this expose together but i was down
in the bahamas interviewing these
victims
right before covet great expose by the
way well thank you it was shocking
in its brutality
and so he's been arrested now
and he's in canada awaiting extradition
he's been indicted in new york
and they're looking at other members of
his circle is he done done
oh he's done okay he's gonna die in
prison he's gonna yeah he's not going to
trial yet they're still messing around
the extradition but he tried to get out
on bond yeah private jet i mean this is
such a shocking case this guy according
to the allegations
would impregnate young women
this is crazy by the way have them brace
for impact yeah race for impact is right
have them
get abortions harvest the stem cells
from the aborted fetus and have them
injected
into his body as some form of uh
fountain of youth we these are the
freaking stories that the q anon talks
about this guy yeah yeah but this is
this is people are basically eating
babies this is real for this what is it
what is it this is something chrome
chrome chrome yeah this is the guy well
i don't think q anon has any insight
into this case kunan has its own thing
separate of this but i can tell you
about the peter nygard case and in the
midst of this two-year investigation we
had
which resulted in the documentary on
discovery plus
you know it would doing this case was
like a 3d game of chess because we had
to get so many people to help and
cooperate and coordinate and there was
competition and and you know to get down
to the bahamas and do these interviews
and in the course of this i get a call
from a guy i know who's involved in
human trafficking investigations and
says you're working on the nygard case
right i said yesterday he goes i need
you to talk to this lawyer i know i said
okay great well it turns out he's the
lawyer for the a guy who is a
videographer for nygard for two or three
years and had hundreds of hours of
videotapes on the private jet going to
asia the pamper parties and gave them to
us
didn't even ask for money
and it was just well it was it was
amazing so imagine we were going to do
the story anyway holy crap but in the
final stretch
to get these videotapes
i mean it was it was it was in terms of
storytelling for television
man oh man
it was incredible did you watch this
yeah i watched it so what ends up
happening is
one of his uh uh
closest who he hires to be his assistant
a very attractive girl he hires him when
she was 17 she stayed with him for a
while
and
one day she's sitting there with the
people that are managing the property
husband and wife that was managing the
property and she writes like on a note
and she says i need help i have to
figure out a way to get out here some
message like that then
nygaard's
top helper in the house a lady
who's seen a lot of this stuff taking
place
one day his sister her sister is there
with her with her and he noticed nygard
taking her sister upstairs
and her sister is 13 years old says what
are you doing and he smiles gives a
smile to her so that the day i saw that
smile i told myself to go to the beach
he says that's when i realized this is
if you're gonna cry you're gonna do it
to my sister
you know and i'm somebody so now you're
going to my 13 year old so we have a
problem here and the next thing all
these guys came together
and flipped and turned against them and
obviously the rest is history
there are people like this out there by
the way and you see similar profiles of
guys like this out there
you know some of the guys nowadays my
thoughts goes to a completely different
place i want to go into that has nothing
to do with this stuff is what is the
what is the
uh playbook of investigative journalism
so walk me through is it something that
applies
an investigative journalist in 911 can
he also go be
uh investigating to peter nygard and can
he also go into investigating a wall
street you know bernie madoff is the
playbook the identical same playbook
is it slightly different well it's
similar i mean there's a template in
terms of what we do
but it often starts with you know a
reporter's intense interest into
something or
you know 40 years into it as i am you
have a lot of contacts and people who
will say you should look into this
and a lot of the material that i come
across including the nycard
investigation came from somebody who is
involved
sometimes a former local or federal law
enforcement person who does this
privately who's working for somebody
that says you need to take a look at
this
and that's how it starts and you you
verify it sometimes it you know you may
find that it's somebody who's got a
personal interest or a vendetta and you
have to approach that differently than
when you find a case like nygard where
this guy's got to be exposed
and and between the pressure that we put
on him and the other media put on him it
was helpful in terms of getting him
indicted and facing charges what do you
think about what james o'keefe is doing
if you said you're recognizing what do
you think about what he's doing i think
that's in a different category i think
when you're doing something
that's potentially politically motivated
and i don't know him i've been contacted
by some of the people who have worked
for him for different stories i have
typically stayed away from it just
because i have questions about how it
works i don't pretend to have intimate
knowledge about how it works but i know
you know he's got a political bent which
is his right
but that's not how i base my journalism
i don't base it because i believe in one
political party over another i i base it
on justice i base it on what people are
interested in i base it on my expertise
and that that is a whole different world
that crosses a lot of different
boundaries he thinks he's justified in
crossing those lines i can't agree with
that do you do you like how oliver stone
does it where he just goes from a
curious place and he goes and wants to
find out you know what putin is about he
goes and sits when he wants to find out
what ukraine's all about he goes and he
wants to find out what castro did he
goes in the jfk he goes through do you
like the style he does it i i do you
just have to remember that it's
one man's opinion sometimes right so
it's point of view it doesn't mean that
that's true it's it's a it's a a work
that is based upon one man's curiosity
and his ability to spin a story so you
know jfk wasn't necessarily
all
true
truth-based maybe
event-based but it's his theory on what
happened as long as you keep that in
mind i think it's fine with it i mean
it's really no different than me saying
okay i want to investigate peter nygard
and putting together a team and getting
a production company or me saying we
need to do more predator investigations
or me saying we're going to go after
this guy who's been assaulting the women
on on social media or any of the other
stories we have going on right now i
mean
we're we got this case
that i just was working on last week
um
exposing
uh in a southern state
what appears to be a human trafficking
ring involving
politically connected people and think
about you ever watch the first series of
true detective
yeah matthew mcconaughey yeah yeah
that's what i lived last week damn
that was in real life some say that some
of the best tv ever produced i i thought
it was and now we're in the thick of
exposing it for real let me ask you to
pat's point because you brought up
o'keeffe you brought up
um oliver stone curious mind
james was keith
what he does is pretty ballsy my
question is
i mean does it take some brass balls to
do this does it take a certain
percentage of a curious mind like
those sit downs where you when you walk
in that room
how intense are they how much balls do
you have to have to just like hey have a
seat buddy we're gonna have a little
talk how do you know they're not gonna
pull out a weapon how do you know like
that your life's not in danger it's a
good question talk about that it's
we bulletproof it as much as possible
right and as the years have gone by
we have trended more closely to working
with law enforcement remember the first
two we did we just went out and did i
had security rodney knight was there was
a you know nbc security guy and former
nypd lieutenant
and so we felt pretty safe but we didn't
have all the background of the guys as
we progressed
and collaborated with law enforcement
starting in the third investigation
it made it safer
we were able to find out more about this
guy does he carry
a pistol does he have a permit to carry
a pistol for instance in fairfield when
the guy showed up he had a gun in his
car
duct tape rope he was on the list to
become a cop he worked for the cable
company
we knew that there was a possibility he
had a gun with him because we could do
that kind of extensive background when
he approached the house
our internal security coached the decoy
and saying turn around i'm worried about
a gun we had a mass shooting here at a
school lift up your shirt as best as we
could and with some other technology
we determined that he probably didn't
have a gun with him so we let him come
in if we think he's carrying the police
will arrest him before he comes in
because we don't need a live gun in that
confined space it's not safe
but to your point the first time i
confronted one of these guys yeah my
heart was in my throat
you still get
a little bit anxious you're very focused
guys put their hands in their pockets
that makes you nervous put them on the
table but you control the environment as
much as possible and i've done it enough
times you know we're getting close to
500 guys now
where i can kind of see the way this is
going but you can never take it for
granted you know we have a lot of
protections in place that we don't show
because we don't want to give those away
and obviously the worst case scenario is
that somebody comes in
tries to do something to get attention
or create harm to themselves or others
and then our security team has to take
action and
badly for everybody involved
we have taken the right steps i think
thus far to prevent that from ever
happening and we continue to tweak that
as we go along
yeah you're always on you're always on
edge when you're doing it that's that's
what that's what makes it what it is
right right if it was easy everybody
could do it
those scenes where they walk in that
room and it is that is
built for tv
well we're taking people into the
commission of a felony they see the
transcripts they see the text they see
what has been said they see the
motivation and then here he comes
and
more often than not they
talk to me
does your job ever make you feel a
certain level of pessimism it seems like
you said the first what two days you had
17 guys then you find out about peter
nygaard and it just seems like every
time it gets a little bit worse and it's
got to be it's got to affect your
outlook on life you know
occasionally i get asked that question
and i'm a pretty optimistic guy actually
you know i i do
have a dim view of some aspects of life
but i guess i've gotten to the point
where
you know i know that there's more good
than bad out there and so i don't i try
not to dwell in it i mean and i'm able
to compartmentalize it i mean i think
when you do something for 40 years you
either let it own you
or you put it in its proper perspective
you know
i have i always had balance in my life i
don't know that you can achieve all this
and do everything i've done and have
balance but i have balance now
you know i'm at a great point in my
career where i can do a lot of different
things you know
and i do and it's very satisfying but i
don't dwell in it i i i i escape it i i
know when to turn it off i you know i
built a day into this trip to come see
you guys by being in the sun yesterday
and and relaxing you got a good time i
feel good yeah you got a really nice
stand yeah now you know
as we're going through this the reason
why i'm asking about the investigative
journal
there's a lot of things i would want to
hire
a professional to go investigate
like if you look at what's going on
today in the world what would i love to
investigate what what what are tens of
millions of people if not billions of
people what is billions of people in the
last 24 months what would they love to
investigate
i think it's only one thing people would
love to investigate the last 24 months
where the hell did this coronavirus
thing come from
what did they do
what happened could we have prevented it
thank god it wasn't as bad as something
else could have been if it was more
deadlier
we lost many lives but it could have
been 50 million it could have been 100
million it could have been a lot more
people than it cost so isn't it worth us
going and investigating that and if we
do what approach do you take how do you
go about it when it's international what
is the right way to do it
are they really going to want to
cooperate do you get people from the
inside to be whistleblowers how do you
protect the whistleblowers to come out
and you know share information because
one of the things that is working out
very well with james o'keefe's model is
now people are calling him who are with
new york times who are in those meetings
who are with
you know the cnns or you know the
foxes or the aoans or whatever networks
it is that they're calling them cbs's
abc's they're calling him and they're
saying listen here's what happened here
they don't want to share the story
because of xyz here's how they protected
this guy here's how they dis and he's
getting google facebook that's pretty
what he's doing
no i understand what you're getting at
so so all i'm saying is i think there is
a business model
and
you know although what catching a child
predator as a parent i'd love for that
show to be on every day because i think
what sometimes you have these shows like
america's most wanted or what was it bad
boys bad boys is that america's house
cops
that was in the 90s you see these things
and some people would say well you know
to catch predator aren't you training
them to even be wiser on what not to do
or are you putting the fear on this and
cops aren't training people how to
commit crime it's an america's most want
is more of a weight training people i
think it potentially is scaring the hell
out of the guys to say you know what i
want to be a little bit more careful i
think the most important thing is
you know when you create an awareness
and a dialogue that didn't exist before
you are achieving your goal so anybody
can say anything about you know you
write a book on financial fraud you know
are you teaching
the next people to
you know mix different kinds of
securities in a toxic soup that creates
the downfall of 2008 no we're teaching
people to avoid getting into that once
again
and it's the same thing in crime
reporting well that was crime reporting
too actually criminal the way this
worked but you know it's it's about
creating awareness and a dialogue and
people are smart enough to make their
own decisions but we're not you know
we're not teaching predators how to prey
on kids
and we're showing how it's done
but i don't think there's ever been a
case where somebody said oh i sought to
catch a predator and chris hanson
verbally lambasted this guy so i'm gonna
go do it now and be smarter and better
is there a show like that on on tv like
network like regular cable tv where
people can watch on a weekly basis what
on the predator thing yeah no we're
shooting them now we're out doing new
ones who are you gonna who you going
it's gonna be it's gonna be on trueblue
the new uh digital crime network that
we're starting and launching in november
oh but it's not like abc or abc's maybe
we're in discussions we're in
discussions about that too so i think it
needs two different levels whatever is
going to be to the most to right and you
got a youtube channel as well with a few
hundred thousand subs and you you're
you've created content on that but uh
let's go to let's go to another story
let's go to another story is this the
one that just came out uh no this is an
older one right professor said who said
pedophiles should be called minor
attracted persons agrees to resign
did you see this story or no i did what
are your thoughts you should resign
children are children they need to be
protected you know you can buy into this
whole minor attracted person's thing and
i'm not an expert in it but
you know anytime you're saying that it's
okay
for an adult to have a
sexual relationship with a with a minor
it's wrong
it just is there's no gray area here you
know people talk about well child porn
is a way for these guys to fulfill their
fantasy without actually touching a kid
no it's not if you go into the prison
and you talk to
dr michael birker works for the us
marshal service who's interviewed
dozens and dozens of these people they
will tell you without exception that
there's a link between the viewing of
child pornography and offending
the viewing of child pornography and
offending and offending it's got to be
very easy to catch that though isn't it
like it can be but you think about i
mean
when people had to buy it
yeah but now it's all over the internet
i mean there are yeah there are multiple
investigations going on every minute of
every day into child porn it's horrible
every time somebody looks at that stuff
it's the re-victimization of a child and
that's why the penalties are so severe
but it's not
easy to find every every image i mean
it's it's it's it's a painstaking
investigation and imagine the
investigator who's got to view this
stuff which is horrible yeah we have we
had a guy on who was a former facebook
auditor do you remember moderating oh my
god
he said the stuff he had to watch on a
daily basis he says we had in the in
this place we had people throwing up we
had people going to the bathroom we had
people like would quit their jobs
because they couldn't believe the
content they had to consume like people
were going insane
the iguana that the guy was hitting his
head and the screaming he says i've
never heard a
animal voice like that yeah but i want
to read something to you that's
concerning because
we're playing a little bit of the
slippery slope with the trans uh
side right and so this story comes at
california trans child molester
hannah tubbs gloats over light sentence
and jailhouse phone calls okay
explicit los angeles jailhouse
recordings of hannah tubbs a 26 year old
trans child molester who re received a
slap on a wrist
in january after pleading guilty to
molesting a 10 year old in 2014 the
picture admitting it was wrong to attack
a little girl but gloating over the
light punishment tubbs pleaded guilty
last month to
the cold case attack which took place in
a woman's restroom at denny's restaurant
when the suspect who was two weeks shy
of 18 and identified as a male named
james tubbs after being arrested roughly
eight years after the crime tubbs began
identifying as a woman she received a
sentence of two years at a juvenile
facility because democrat district
attorney george
okay so how how concerned are you with
what's happening today with
the trans side where laws are almost
protecting against i think somebody even
had a
did somebody have a sex change to
prevent from having a long sentence
this was a two months ago story do you
remember that one story where somebody
did this
how much of a slippery slope are we
dealing with when it comes down to the
to this uh i think if you take this case
and isolate it i think the more
the question is
you know did this person i mean take the
trans out of it for a minute there was a
sexual assault of a minor
uh
but they didn't catch the person until
they were older so at the time of the
crime
what was the age difference
now gloating about getting away with it
is horrible and wrong
and and that person probably deserved a
higher sentence i'm not so sure that in
this case
being trans had anything to do
with the sentence i think it had more to
do with the age
of the person when the crime was
committed and i know that there
there have been
a lot of criticisms of this particular
district attorney out there and i know
people who work in that office who think
that you know he's too light on some of
these crimes and they don't go after
some of the stuff aggressively enough
but i think in this case the trans issue
gets a headline because
of what it is
but the real matter of the case is that
somebody got away with a light sentence
whether they're trans or not
yeah you see so you know the the the
topic about
you know the pizza guy okay with the
piece he's like well it was consent yeah
what do you mean you can't just
certainly what are you talking about
right this is a guy he had a marriage
contract this guy was a bad guy
right and i've gone back to some of
these guys 44 years old at the time yeah
jeff sokol and i went back to him to
reach out as i do with many of these
guys to get them to see if they'll talk
to me on the podcast because i think it
would be interesting and i've been in
discussions with some of them who
i think may do it jeff said yes jeff
said no okay i'm not surprised but yeah
here is so so maybe you've brought some
awesome pizza yeah they planted pizza
from the part the part about the
slippery slope is
you know
the law today states what at what age
uh uh uh if you have sex with a minor
it's what 18 it's under 18. depending on
the state okay it's different but it it
can be it's usually 18
unless both parties are under 18. so in
other words if if
if a
15 year old girl has actually a 16 year
old boy in a lot of states that's not
illegal
right because the age difference is
in some states it is illegal no
in some states it may be i don't know
the law in every state but i know that
in many states if both parties are
within a year of each other and under
age it's not illegal
if one party is 30 and one is 15 then
that's illegal right and then the gray
area comes when somebody as you
mentioned earlier somebody's 16
somebody's 19 is that inappropriate i
can tell you
that during our investigations
profile the the
the target is
at the oldest 14 because it takes that
gray area out of it so in other words
if it's a 19 year old and a 13 14 13 or
12 year old child
you can say well he's only 19. but then
i would argue that okay what's the
difference between a 19 year old
violating a 12 year old and a 38 year
old what's the difference i brought this
up to to a guy i was speaking to
uh about the 19 year old and the 15 year
old and i said what do you think about
that well you know that's that's not
cool uh you shouldn't be doing that i
said okay how about a 60 year old dating
a 20 year old
mm-hmm
16 years i think i think a 20-year-old
is of legal age in terms of consent so
you know it may look creepy but it's not
illegal yeah
so so the the
the law for me that i'm going to with
trans is the following they're trying to
pass
are you following the story that they're
trying to
allow a minor to make a decision to have
a sex change how does that and they're
talking about the scene in seattle in
seattle the minor doesn't even have to
get the parent's permission and it's
against the law for the physician to
tell the parent that the minor wants a
sex change this is happening in a lot of
places across the country
well i think you know you get into a
really complicated area here because
and i'm not expert in it by any stretch
of the imagination but i do you know
read up on it because
you know it's interesting
um
there are cases where
somebody at a young age thinks they want
to have
gender reassignment surgery
and then has regrets afterwards now how
do you put that back together once it's
happened so
just like in a lot of other areas you
know
there's mandatory counseling before you
take certain steps
and it would seem this is one of them
and again you know this is all new so
we're all making this up as we go along
we don't know
but there is there is information out
there that suggests that in a certain
number of cases
people feel that they want to do this
and then they have regrets and second
thoughts and they want to reverse it and
that's difficult
if not impossible washington laws
now allow teen gender reassignment
surgery without parental consent
that's just weird to me you tell me how
that makes any sense what comes after
that
you know what comes after that to say
what's wrong with a 22 year old dating a
13 year old i mean i'm from iran in iran
the age used to be a 50 year old man
could marry a 13 year old girl and when
the shah got elected i think you raise
it to 15 maybe 18. it's back down to 13
today by the way today a 50 year old man
can marry 13 i think
it's 13 years old right now and it's
normal there
what if now you know stories like this
end up passing on people oh you gotta
let's their choice it's their choice and
people say
i think
is is too old i think we got lowered up
to 15.
should we fight that
it's a law right
should we say okay what if there comes a
town where they change the law from 18
to 15. and half the country agrees and
they say what's wrong with that what
what are we doing now now people can't
say well that's just the law now we have
to follow that law
well i think sometimes common sense
loses out and i think we have to
find this middle ground you know we get
so polarized in so many aspects of
politics and
everything else that we're going through
today you know you get to the covet
thing i mean yes there's a great story
there and i'm talking to a lot of people
about that is it hard to get to china
yes is it hard to get the truth out of
china absolutely i've been there i've
done stories there but
we do lose common sense sometimes and i
think this is an area i mean i don't
think a 13 year old
should be able to decide
on their own surgery no matter what the
surgery we're on the same page
and this is the only thing in this whole
area that i can tell you for sure is
that
when you have a potential transgender
issue in your family the rate of suicide
is dramatically lower when a family is
open and accepting and has a discussion
that i can tell you that i know for a
fact
other than that
you know we're making new
new decisions in in an area that we
haven't dealt with before
how much do we have transgenderism in
the 20s
so go to 20s and 30s
what was transgenderism in the 20s and
30s like this whole thing to say if it's
accepted by parents
it didn't didn't didn't we just read an
article that said the number one step to
uh
you know somebody abusing your kid the
first step is to win the trust of who
the parents i mean that's the same
argument as saying chris i may be wrong
is to say
let's first get the parents to accept
the concept of their kids wanting to go
through it
and then once we win their parents over
and then we can get the kids but we
first have to get the parents to think
that it's normal
because
i don't i don't know if you know this
topic was a topic and i'd love to get
more of the history of it on when it
started you know i'd love to see
uh in the 30s was it a normal thing was
it normal to talk about these types of
surgeries i mean i know it's been around
for a while but
i want to know the the
the what's the word i want to know the
history
not only the history of it you know
again from an investigative journalistic
standpoint like i want to know the
out of a thousand people that did the
surgery i want to know the profile i
want to know the parenting i want to
know at what age i want to know
you know uh
siblings do they have an older sister
older brother what's the relationship
with the older brother sister was there
an abusive uncle or person i want i want
to investigate that i want to know that
but we're so afraid to investigate that
all we're investigating is well parents
should be more acceptable about this
this this and that and i think
rather than doing that we're not putting
the time into the real conversation
which is
you know suicide in the military why
does suicide in the military happen what
is it
what causes suicide in the military to
happen
you know is it
away from the family did some people
join the military to get away from the
family are they running away from family
you mean to tell me everybody that joins
the army is that patriotic i have a hard
time believing it when i was in the
military i had a lot of guys that were
in the military they were not in there
because they were patriotic there were
people that were in the military that
actually didn't like the country they
were just people in the military for gi
bill some were there because they
couldn't stand their dad they wanted to
get away
and we had stories of
what he called it uh suicide and it's
heartbreaking you know i had one of my
uh close uh friends from you know
military that went through it and i saw
his relationship with his father
his father would slap him in the face in
front of us
and i'm like i can't i can't even be
around it his father was so abusive to
him in front of all of us
and he would be so embarrassed when he
was around us so
he never felt like he could do anything
to please his dad and eventually took
his life was that the reason so
education is what it comes down that's
what i'm going to say and awareness in a
dialogue that's all i want to know i
like when you said you said something
about james o'keefe you said that's an
opinion
and then he said oliver stone is an
opinion right that's an opinion well the
opinion is on both sides right
you said you want to get to what was the
word you used not the truth you said you
want to do
uh you given which i agree with you want
to find out the why let's just say all
right
the origin of georgia i want to know the
why i want to know you know there's a
lot of questions i got i want to know do
we really make the right choice go in a
war in iraq you know and we're like oh
that weapon is a mass destruction guess
what what was that
what was this whole thing with the way
we handled afghanistan that was
catastrophic we just lost 80 billion
dollars this whole thing going on with
russia and ukraine right now what is the
real motive does america is america
using ukraine as a proxy to get rid of
putin we don't know i want to know i'm
curious right i'm curious to know
what some of the some of these things
are historically
you haven't been in this space for a
while who's who was the name of people
that would go investigate the heavy duty
topics
that would come and give the most uh
fair assessment from both sides i mean
cronkite was more of a
personality guy because i was like the
investigative journalist that would give
both sides of the story
yeah i think uh i think the 60 minutes
guys obviously in
mike wallace sure uh our friend john
stossel stossel did a lot of great work
over the years
um
in a whole combination walt bogdanovich
you know at the new york times and other
places
and the whole teams of
print reporters who would go after this
chicago tribune
going back to you know the the
meatpacking uh industry uh you know
upped in sinclair and you know uh
talking about all that
the chicago papers did a great thing
where they opened up a bar
and they
saw everybody hitting them up for bribes
the inspectors and the contractors it
was but it was it was a seminal we once
had a story put together
where we had some guys come in and we
were going to open up a gentleman's club
a strip club
and watch
the people come in in new york city we
had a location everything from the mob
supplying the dancers to the people
inspecting the place to do the whole
thing and then put hidden cameras in and
capture the whole thing and the lawyers
ended up nixing it because there are
admittedly a lot of
issues doing that um you know how long
do you run it but the interesting thing
was that the guys were consulting with
me on it
said that they could pay for the entire
project with the proceeds of actually
having a club in queens
and it got pretty high up and let me see
right now we're gonna open us we had a
name for you the whole thing didn't
happen but it didn't have well and and i
understand why i mean
the legal questions were
just overwhelming and strangling of
doing something no question but i mean
and then
you know you're operating this thing and
you've got legitimate people working
there
people going there as customers do you
you know what do you do
yeah why are the places with hidden
cameras
and that's constitutionally
iffy i mean it'd be great television
but i mean the lawyers
and the best part was in the pitch
meeting i said and it pays for itself
you know because we'd raise it was going
to be 400 grand to do it
and i think we're going to make back 400
grand in the first year and we actually
had
former
federal and local law enforcement people
who were going to consult on this who
had done this for other investigations
and it was i thought it was genius but i
understood at the end of the day what
the why it was 400 grand to do it and
you're going to get 400 grand back i
mean that would be
perfect tv right
yeah but then you know you got a guy who
goes into a club like that for one night
and he gets captured on the hidden
camera you know what do you do with that
yeah and you got a woman who's working
in that business because she's trying to
feed her kids
what do you do with that at what point
does it become exploitive
versus interesting notwithstanding
all the other legal issues
out of the 500 people that you dealt
with did anybody ever sue you out of the
500 did you ever get sued by them or no
there were
excuse me there were some attempts um
none of them successful and the the
reason is it's it's so clear
right these aren't gray area cases
the majority of the
crime is committed
in the online solicitation showing up is
just
the television part they arrest the the
end the culmination of it
yes what james said james said you know
i want to see it on video when you see
it on video right it's real it's not
like it's hearsay you but they saw them
they made criminal cases on the
transcripts on the on the online channel
really all the time really yeah
on online that's did you hear that
because it's a solicitation so if on a
dm an adult is going through with a 13
year old that can be crossed that
threshold that's the case that's great
that's the case okay that's great too
here yeah when they show up
they often make statements to me that
you know if they admit the crime yeah
obviously that can be used but but i've
never even been called
to testify in one of these cases because
it's so clear-cut hell yeah
sounds like pat wants to put together a
a team a task force a team
you james o'keefe
um john walsh from america's most wanted
what was the guy from cheaters uh joey
grieco
and go down to wuhan and get that thing
forward wallace was also wallace's
father
did you watch it that's wonderful about
his father
michael i'll tell you a funny story so
i'm in miami one time and i'm off and
he's i run into mike wallace who's uh
who's working doing something he was
doing an interview with somebody and um
and i introduced myself he goes oh chris
yeah sure
what was it that i just saw that you did
that was so good i couldn't wait to tell
him and he probably didn't see it but
because i explained it in such details
oh yeah that was really good but he was
such a consummate pro
you know it's not like i knew him well
but the couple times that i met him he
was gracious and kind and
during the predator the media coverage
of the predator story
i was
you know likened to him and it was a
great compliment to me
he was i mean he did something he did
khomeini yeah he did uh uh
the shaw multiple times he sat man he
sat down with everybody
you know he was yeah mike what was that
his documentary i am mike wallace who
was mike i don't know what it is but i
know what's great you know i'm watching
him to learn about his story go ahead
well pat brought up walter cronkite
we're talking about mike wallace people
just think that you know
on the face of it you're just this guy
to catch a predator you're a real
journalist you went to school for
journalism you've done all this i wanted
to get your thoughts on just the overall
distrust in media these days oh it's
fake news you can't trust anybody
everything's so polarized you know jeff
zucker resigns roger ale um you know
cuomo just just so much distrust in news
these days as a news man this must be a
little disheartening for you it is and i
think what you've seen is
besides targeting by politicians you
know in this
catch phrase fake news i mean the
reality is nobody's perfect in the news
business nobody's perfect in politics
nobody's perfect in the financial world
but generally most of the people try to
do the right thing
but with the advent of cable news and
this need or perceived need to take a
point of view
you know fox obviously had a point of
view and it made them successful
their news reporting during the day is
their news reporting but when you get to
personalities and point of view at night
the same with msnbc or the same at cnn
it creates polarization
and it creates targeting
and i think when you elevate that for
ratings you take the risk
of being painted on one side or the
other and we've lost what happens at 6
30 for the evening news and we lost what
happens between
10 in the morning and and 5 at night on
cable news which is generally speaking
reporting i mean you you watch on fox
you see their correspondent in ukraine
showing this incredible story all day
long and then you get to some of the
columnist opinionator opinionated people
and they're telling a whole different
story and saying what's wrong with putin
and everything else when all day long
their guys have been dodging mortar
shells in the field yeah telling the
real story do you think
there should be a disclaimer like
opinion journalism
versus the actual news the viewer needs
to be aware
of what you're looking at but there's
such a gray line it is it is and that's
like you're watching this you're
watching the four o'clock news
uh with brett bear and then next on the
five is a bunch of opinions right so you
got to switch your mind over that was
the news now it's opinions same thing on
cnn it goes from wolf blitzer to boom
now it's don lemon and now you're
so
do you think the media needs to be held
accountable to say
this is the news portion facts this is
the opinion portion take it with a grain
of salt i think i think there's they
need to use it
the best consumer is an educated
consumer and so i think you know there
is a certain responsibility that we have
but also i think the you know the people
watching
need to know and be aware that look this
has just crossed from over over from
reporting in journalism to somebody's
opinion but you're putting that on the
people just well i think a consumer
i think people i think people know it i
i do this maybe maybe they should maybe
i'm not saying i'm not saying you're
wrong by the way i'm just saying that
you know are we insulting to the viewer
by saying okay we're leaving the news
portion of the day and here's this
personality doing it i mean i think
people sort of know that maybe you're
right
i'm not arguing it i'm just saying that
you know i when i
answer these questions when i look at
these situations i try to give the
viewer who was generally incredibly
intelligent
you know credit for being are you giving
the viewer too much credit chris
i don't think so
i mean maybe some
but i mean i i think i think
what does denzel say denzel says uh if
you watch the news
you're misinformed if you don't watch
the news you're uninformed you've got to
pick one of the two right you're going
to be missing that's pretty good that's
uninformed right one of the two anyways
chris it's uh it's been great having you
on uh appreciate you for coming out
thanks for having me uh we're gonna put
the link below tyler if you can put the
link below to his youtube channel is
there any other links you would want the
folks to go check out we have the
podcast predators i've caught with chris
hanson that's on all platforms now
we've got watch trueblue
you can get updates uh in the ramp up to
the launch of that uh discovery plus
onision in real life and uh unseemly the
peter nygard investigation and a lot of
stuff in the pipeline let's put that all
in the description as well the chat and
for some of you guys that support nick
mckinley's work
he messaged me yesterday they are
working right now to relocate 30 000
orphans from various locations in
ukraine to poland just like the
afghanistan
there's a budget that's needed for this
crisis we put the link below tyler put
that again they're trying to raise 450
000
they've raised a little over a hundred
thousand dollars still needed another
350. if you support what he's doing
please go find it in your heart if you
do to support his cause to get to 450.
uh are we doing podcasts again this
thursday or no tomorrow tomorrow with mr
mike baker oh we got mike baker tomorrow
cia mike baker okay sounds good so if
you like the cia stuff and we've had
mike on before join us tomorrow on the
podcast with mike baker take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
you